over thousands of years we've been
experienced uh deaiing consciousness and
metaphysics only recently since the
scientific revolution has a global
paradigm of materialism become dominant
industrialization has connected billions
of people to electricity and the
internet plus much more the revelation
of quantum mechanics blew our minds and
now the 21st century is knocking how can
science possibly probe the most primal
question of our existence what is
consciousness if you'll join me for a
moment in a game I'd like to ask you to
close your eyes and imagine you are in
bed dozing off you immediately begin
dreaming that you're in a kitchen
pouring yourself some tea your adoring
the high quality of this full immersion
where you can literally even smell the
aroma you accidentally spill a little
and suddenly you snap back to laying in
your bed with your eyes open what you
just experienced we predict is a
microcosm reflecting the macrocosm in
other words the same way we dream a
reality and take a first-person
perspective is precisely what we are
doing with this reality it's recursive
reality calls on us to dream for one
third of our lives quite an obvious hint
one indivisible infinite consciousness
in a dream fully immersed in the high
quality completely forgetting it is a
dream why we see people running around
seeking objects relationship substances
anything is because they want to /
pierce the veil of separation to feel
whole the irony is you already are what
you seek
Rupert how was that was pretty good I
can't add much to that okay actually if
if you know if that's if that's the case
then that makes me happy I'm always
happy but that makes me especially happy
because it's very
important to me to take what these
diverse leaders like yourself around the
world are communicating and be able to
try and compress the messages into the
most relatable stories which is
basically what you do with your
metaphors and yes you've said infinite
consciousness is the ultimate dreamer
whose activity is the universe yes I
really like that as well